欸，你聽過迪士尼他們訓練員工的方式嗎？我最近看到一篇文章，發現很多地方跟我們想的不太一樣。
迪士尼的訓練？嗯，我猜啦，不就是那些強調「魔法」、「奇蹟」什麼的，把員工洗腦得很開心去服務顧客嘛。聽起來有點假。
其實我一開始也有點懷疑，但文章裡提到一個點很有意思。他們在佛羅里達的「迪士尼大學」裡，竟然蓋了假的飯店房間跟模擬大廳。
假的？這是幹嘛用的？演戲給誰看？成本划算嗎？
就是讓新進的房務人員可以練習打掃、前台人員練習辦理入住。重點是，這些練習都在「沒有顧客」的環境下進行，可以盡情犯錯。
等等，這裡我有疑問。一般公司會這麼做嗎？像我們餐廳，新來的學徒不都是直接進廚房或上外場，邊做邊學嗎？這樣不是效率更高？
這就是出乎意料的地方。文章說，讓員工在低風險的環境中排練，先犯錯、再改進，就能避免他們在真正的顧客面前出包。你想想，如果一個新員工第一次服務就搞砸，是不是可能直接失去這個客人？
嗯，你這麼說有點道理。但這要花錢蓋實體模擬場景耶，對一般中小企業來說，這筆開銷怎麼可能負擔得起？
其實這點我很認同。文章也提到，這不是要每個公司都蓋一個模擬中心。而是提醒我們，要為員工創造一個「安全的練習空間」。不一定是實體空間，可能是先讓他們在內部測試產品、先模擬情境對話，甚至只是主管在旁邊手把手帶幾次。
這樣聽起來就比較可行了。所以，關鍵是讓員工有機會犯錯，但這個錯誤不會直接影響到顧客體驗。這點我是信了。
對，而且他們不只訓練技巧，更強調「創造快樂」這個核心目標。這點我覺得很厲害。
「創造快樂」？這很迪士尼啊，感覺很抽象，員工真的會買單嗎？跟每天要擦桌子、掃地有什麼關係？
這也是文章裡強調的。他們在一個叫「傳統」的課程裡，不斷告訴員工，你們不是來「掃地」或「指路」的，而是來「創造快樂」的。他們希望讓每個員工都理解，自己的工作最終是為了這個更大的目標服務。
意思是，即使是停車場的服務員，他的職責也不是單純指揮交通，而是讓客人進園區的第一個接觸點就感到開心？這點要怎麼落實？
像文章裡舉例，園區裡清潔人員不只掃地，還會主動幫客人指路。因為他們理解，客人來玩是為了開心，而迷路會影響心情，所以他們不分職責，只要能幫助客人「創造快樂」的事，他們都會去做。
這點其實不容易做到。很多公司會把職責劃分得很清楚，員工就只做自己份內的事，深怕多做多錯。
所以這就是迪士尼與眾不同之處。他們不混淆「任務」和「工作」。任務是打掃、是引導，但「工作」的核心是創造快樂。當員工把這個目標刻在心裡，遇到突發狀況時，就能做出符合公司精神的判斷。
這樣看來，這不只是服務業，任何產業都適用。如果工程師接到客戶電話，他即使不是業務，也知道要把這個潛在客戶導向對的人，而不是直接說「這不是我的工作」。
沒錯，就是這個意思。還有一個點是關於產品測試的。迪士尼對於員工的制服，會用到很極端的方式去測試。
制服？極端測試是怎麼說？是拿去火燒還是水洗幾百次？
文章提到，他們在佛羅里達這種濕熱的環境，會讓員工穿著新的制服在園區裡走動，然後積極收集他們的意見。就是用最可能失敗的條件去測試產品，而且是讓第一線的「使用者」給回饋。
喔，這個叫「內部試用」（dogfooding）吧。但通常公司會覺得這些是成本，讓員工自己反應不就好了？還要專門去收集嗎？
這邊的數字很有趣。迪士尼光是服裝部門就有 46 個地點、1500 名員工，超過 900 種制服設計，光帽子就有 746 種款式。他們這麼大規模，都還願意花資源去聽員工的意見，來確保制服的舒適度和實用性。
等等，這是說他們有 250 萬件服裝在流通？這規模確實很大。這樣一來，每一件衣服的舒適度都會影響到員工的工作狀態，進而影響服務品質。
對。所以對我們這些創業者或主管來說，是不是也該多聽聽第一線員工對產品或流程的意見？他們往往才是最了解實際操作問題的人。
嗯，有道理。如果我是主管，我會先問我的員工，他們現在穿的制服有沒有什麼地方不舒服，或是工作流程有沒有哪裡卡卡的。這點比想像中重要。
其實這幾個點，雖然來自迪士尼這樣的大公司，但背後的邏輯對我們這些小規模的經營者，甚至是普通上班族，都很有啟發。
確實，從模擬練習、理解工作目標，到聽取第一線反饋，這些都能讓我們在自己的崗位上做得更好。
好像也提醒了我們，即使是看似簡單的服務，背後也藏著一套完整的設計與執行體系。
那麼，下次我們討論別的案例時，也可以想想，我們能不能也從中「偷學」到什麼實用的點子呢？